welcome guys before the video starts do
check it out it's a brilliant app for
those who want to pray
salah and share the rewards check them
out now
and you are the same woman looking at me
in the eyes insulting allah and you were
upset because i said i'll put you in
your place
i'll put you in your place you made your
point and you and you were stuck in your
place
people cannot answer
right excuse me madam firstly uh we have
a bit of a history
so yes we do yes we do are you not are
you not the person i speak to on twitter
you oh so sorry thank you for specific
no it wasn't retweeted it was algorithms
just i'm recording for something yeah
you know i study tech right so i know
what algorithms are yes
okay so so twitter doesn't work with
algorithms
no it does but that's not an algorithm
you want this number you'll be
specific i'm saying i was speaking no it
was a tweet no you're semantics i was
speaking no you wasn't it was a tweet
no it wasn't a tweet it was me typing no
it was me thought it was electric
i need it you can order on amazon it's
the top seller
if i had another copy i would give it to
you but i need it to reference
you can order an amazon top seller i
don't want to give you my money
do you know it's me it's my teacher
because
he's silencing women when they talk yes
when he gives me the funding i'll go and
beat my wife at home
i'll go this is what they are i hope
your wife gives you what for at home
give me what i hope you can see like
okay can we just finish this yes
yeah but the microphone needs to be it's
not a good microphone
and it'll be louder what were you guys
talking about on twitter
i think she was hurt because i turned my
back to her you didn't turn your back on
yes i did
no she had the old recording did you see
the thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah well i was living in it yeah the in
part no you didn't turn your back on me
i didn't i think it's such a camera's
not going to see you if you do that it's
such
it's so sad that you feel the need
to end a discussion and i put her in her
place or i swept the floor with her i
don't said that i don't know
i said i have a point in the place yes
and that was not true
it was true you know yeah can i finish
myself yes yes yes all right so
if you let me talk i'll let you okay
okay right because it's disrespectful
and i won't talk
um i think it's so disappointing that
you have to finish an argument with
i put her in her place that is not a
constructive discussion
that is nothing i never said that i
never dehumanized somebody even called
you jihadi and you know who took your
side
but you know why i did that because
you're not because from what i know
i'll do the same if it's being true yeah
i'll do the same if someone's lying
again
i don't know this you claim that but i
don't know this but anyways
i did not i would i would not conflate
those terms but the fact that you had to
go to that extent
to win an argument it was never about
winning it was about having discretion
how two people
can disagree fundamentally unlike
religion right
i'm an atheist you're a muslim i left
islam we disagree
you claim you left islam we're not going
back there we are going to go back we
can go back here
what do you mean i'll get to it okay
i we can disagree fundamentally but the
fact that you had to put that
called me girl call me having girly
issues yeah maybe
it is very you don't know that i don't
know about you you use behavior like
that so
what are you happy man are you having
manly issues maybe i was that day
okay well is that okay for me
philosophy
when somebody says you have girly issues
how would you girls feel don't point the
camera at them
would you like it if somebody says
you're having girly issues because you
disagree
no matter what it is it's not okay i
are you upset no i am trying to call you
out on how discussions should be made
okay we can disagree
we can still respect each other right
this is interesting
we can disagree we can respect each
other yes and we don't have to put
people in places we can have a
conversation going like
we disagreed okay that's fine and
the reason that clip was uploaded one it
wasn't edited it was exactly what i had
and the armin uploaded the whole thing
yeah and there was nothing more to it
right
and i felt like that was just very
dis not just respectful but it was just
it just made your argument weaker
when you feel that that's what you do
that's what you have i feel like i
debate people
and i have missing family and we we
disagree fundamentally
if you want to be heard you need to
listen you need to listen
okay i that's what i learned from all of
this okay that you need to listen
so i feel like that was just a weaker
position and that's where my distaste
for
you putting me in my place okay right
because you're not only
showing to other people or other muslims
that you're sexist but you're pushing
people away you're literally
somebody commented on your wallet like
ali this is
don't you think you should be better
than that no no no no no no you don't
think that ending debates or arguments
by
you know things like i put her in her
place
sweeping the floor with her swimming
floor put another place yeah
you know put her down you don't think
they're condescending okay
no you don't think they're condescending
no not at all okay so you're gonna move
that position
yeah i'll tell you what i but let me
speak as well
let me speak as well yeah okay so you
you've come here
oh do you seem upset and you see i'm not
upset
yeah you seem upset and emotional
because i said that i'll put you in your
place
and i'll stick by it i'll put you in
your place why
i turned my back against you yeah and
you was very annoyed about that now why
was you annoyed about that
you're talking about being respectful
you're talking about all these things
and when i listen to you
i'll be honest with you look i'm
peaceful
yeah that doesn't mean that if i feel
threatened i'm not gonna fight
that doesn't mean i throw roses around i
don't say that doesn't mean i throw
roses about
that doesn't mean i'm that christian who
says god is love love love
sorry there's a time and place for
everything and there's a time and place
for each individual as well right so i
believe at that point you deserve that
and i stick by that
okay you are somebody who's coming here
emotionally
talking like you're to make us cry when
you're the same person
who came and insulted allah you're
swearing at allah
and now you're upset emotionally
yeah because you felt that i have saved
you or offended you
and you are the same woman looking at me
in the eyes insulting allah
and you were upset because i said i'll
put you in your place i'll put you in
your place
you made your point and you and you were
stuck in your place and my turn so
please i don't want to talk no no you
insulted allah
do you apologize do you apologize
you were being emotional this is what
you're being you're being emotional
can i finish i'm talking to him i'm
talking to him to the future
and you insult him no no she said it
first
let me finish when i'm done you guys can
interject
i can't let me finish oh no paper music
is different than insulting people i
took your side and i did not insult you
thank you for taking myself thank you
let me finish yes okay i'll let you talk
my turn to talk yes right sorry let me
just clean this up a bit insulting an
idea it's very different from insulting
a person
yes right no no no
yes it is no okay well can you respect
my idea that i don't think your god is
real
and that i do not like your god and his
sadistic can you respect that
i couldn't respect if you said you don't
believe in my god but if you swear
yeah but can you then why can't you
respect my idea about it i just
i disagree with your worldview but i
don't insult
you or insult someone that's dear to you
you're saying i can swear allah but yes
yes but allah says to us if people like
you come that is better
that i i all i did was turn my back i
didn't swear are you talking i didn't
drop to your level i said look i
talked to my back i wasn't even talking
to you that's all i did to your mate
no you were talking to me but i cut it i
cut it and you couldn't taste it
ego it doesn't exist in a good discourse
no we can talk later i'm not i'm not
letting anybody else interrupt me
i'm not going to let anybody else
interrupt him right
somebody that's dear to you or something
that's here to you does not exist for me
so i can insult it no problem
you can i don't want to talk to you then
yeah okay i don't want to talk to you
why did you ask me to come here i didn't
ask you to come you told me
no no no no tell me
i would not like to talk to you anymore
that's okay can i okay can i hurry
with what i'm doing then yeah you asked
thank you you literally asked me to come
out there no please it's fine i don't
want to talk to you okay thank you
by the way thank you for defending me
but besides i don't want to talk to you
and i will defend you if somebody comes
and calls you a host i would tell them
shut up
you already set that precedence by
putting me in my place in girly issues
me putting it in place
you do realize how sexy madam you can
use those arguments sexist
uh patriarchy these are just little you
know like i said people can see through
it
you don't come here and cry when you're
insulting allah and then i said i put
you in your place and you're upset just
because i did this
that's what i did i showed them my back
and you're crying is it because you got
emotional
because you was emotional and that's the
difference between us
of course there is a difference just to
that level to do it
you have you insulted a lot i never
thought you did oh he's turning your
back can i can i can i speak to you sir
i just have a skype call at six i see
you at halftime you've got 10 minutes
let's talk you claim to be an ex-muslim
i am okay what made you leave islam
oh so my struggle started with islam
uh with an inter-sectarian differences
did you mind coming here
do you mind giving him space please i
only i literally have five minutes no
problem five
it's fine
yes